alors on va faire une hardy view
attention dans les bouges ton original
vous avez bougé par l'ingénieur michel
c'est parce que j'ai fait j'ai fait des
bêtises
c'est à dire que d'habitude c'est baffie
qui bouge là je ne trouve pas il a été
très simple et très bien mon bras
l'humeur va rallumer bêtise j'ai bu vos
paroles je n'ai pas écouté
alors attention nord ne bouge pas par
ici on bouge mais c'est l'école non
attention les gars font piéger par rené
l'émission c'est des conneries faut pas
l'écouter on ébauche pendant le dîner on
n'est pas fatigué
vous
c'est mitigé non mais là il n'y a pas
franchement une folie d'affichiste monte
alors bougez michel michel pourrait
bouger là
non sans blague michael alors attention
première qu on va pas déconner trop ah
non non
attention vous feront pas compatible
avec match que je vais me dire dès
maintenant vous avez une grande que mon
frère vous êtes blagueur et mystique des
sculptures ou si vous êtes blagueur et
mystique
c'est incompatible tous croient non
justement c'est bien quand on retrouve
ces deux qualités je suis la même
personne trouve ça bien à moi je mets
d'ailleurs je vais à l'église pour rire
et au diable pour plus reculées
michel serrault quand vous vous regardez
le matin dans la glace vous dites quoi
j'ai un peu vieilli n'a payé tous et
tout connu mon gaz non 108
ah oui ça paraît quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois
écoutez je vais vous faire une
confidence puisqu il n'y a pas souvent
un jeu je ris comme je pleurais je ris
comme france gall et et c'est bien parce
que le gars qui sait pas pleurer et bien
ne sais pas rires
et l'inversé brève et fontenay le disais
tout ce que je ne peux pas toucher tout
ce que je ne peux pas comprendre tout ce
que ma tête ma raison ou ma science ne
peut pas définir où trouver ça n'existe
pas vas-y don nelson n'existerait alors
j'ai pleuré quand j'ai vu un
et quand il dit à la fin sur son lit là
un mot formidable souffle il dit ce sont
des soupirs il dit je me regrette
ouais hein c'est beau alors tu achètes
pas vous regrettez cristal profiter et
mais moi je dis aux gens à aimer aimer
n'importe quoi aimer le pinard et mais
c'est vrai parce qu'on commence par le
pinard et puis vous allez montez les
escaliers bien sûr vrai un homme une
femme des enfants et vieillards
vous aimerez faire plaisir vous aimerez
à tant de choses mais mettez en route ce
qu'ont à l'afp qu'ils appellent le coeur
et vous savez que le coeur il est fait
pour battre alors ayez ce sentiment
d'amour de temps en temps aimer c'est
drôle je n'entends pas qui va essayer de
faire battre votre coeur
oui j'ai fait rien nous je souhaitais
enchères à l'omh notre dame
et si chez les curés comme vous ils
étaient plus de monde dans les églises
vous changeriez quoi on vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique mais je crois
que je changerais rien moi on peut pas
changer
non il faut assumer ce qu'on ait fait
que le pardon que j'ai une bosse sur le
nez parce que c'était bon c'est arrivé
comme ça je veux dire c'est un outil
utile à un ennui de santé etc
ben je me regarde je dirais qu'il ya
plus grave
il a fallu jambes et c'est sûr il faut
parfois faux pas peut-être que ça c'est
la soupe peut-être que si je suis bien
dans le film la danse paysans c'est très
compact et blu ray donc merci mon dieu
d'avoir une grotte seul mais maintenant
faut pas recommencer
vous qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater par le nerf par le nez avec le
nez c'est fait je me ça c'est une
confidence n'écoutait pas moi oui vous
n'aurez même pas t'aimer serment prêté
jamais nous faudrait refaire beaucoup de
choses là oui mais on voudrait si jamais
fini il mettrait acteurs est alors bon
bah je voudrais aussi alors qu'est ce
que je voudrais faire
je voudrais qu'on cinéma ofas comme au
théâtre je voudrais jouer tous les jours
c'est ça la force du théâtre alors soit
on fit commun il sait bien le jour il
est où il a été magnifique
effectivement il est revenu puis il a
joué depuis dix ans émis avant-hier les
six qui se dit vie vous allez voir en
lui mais l'idée vous allez voir un
prêtre mage est la bonne je serait
formidable
au cinéma c'est fait s'est figé il faut
j'aimerais revenir sur la question
thierry ya pas des fois où vous regardez
sur l'écran il apparaît pas où vous êtes
et pathé vous avez six séquences pas
impactés j'ai revu parce que j'ai droit
à la cage aux folles tous les ans
général ma femme me dire il ya la cage
aux dunes au coach ça va je connais et
puis je suis resté je dis je vais me
coûter de la musique ou lire je m'en
vais
et puis j'ai vu le générique j'étais
debout là derrière le fauteuil me suis
dit tu devrais pas le dire mais j'ai
riche vivier risque cette mode des gîtes
maisons siouxsie quel culot il faudrait
bien sûr ça oui et dans les trois
prochains mois
c'est un peu inégal il ya des gros
diamant c'est vrai bon ne peut pas être
pas ça peut pas être parfait partout
mais même dans la dernière case avec
galabru
quand je suis dans le gâteau j'étais par
terre dans mon challenge d'ulysse ont
gonflé quand même ces deux acteurs là
alors attention quand le téléphone sonne
vous êtes heureux ou agacés jeu c'est à
dire je suis heureux parce que quand ça
ne sonne pas c'est un peu malheureux là
et quand ça sonne tous obligés de
décrocher une vie quel est le con qui
m'appelle mal à vous êtes tous temps
vous avez là on est tous comme ça à mes
yeux c'est vrai qu'elle est la dernière
chose que vous faites avant de vous
coucher
mais je fais ma prière
j'ai un moment d'arrêt ouais je fais ma
prière
alors allez un peu bizarroïdes je
demande un tas de choses ou jeux de mots
de rien fait un constat est une espèce
examen de conscience avant de vous
coucher ses pannes et un bain de foule
puis comment ça s'est passé aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt à la baisse ou à la hausse
ou ses plats où on peut être aussi à peu
découragé où on dit on en a marre qu'est
ce que peut faire le débit lent ouais
mais il faut faire attention
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai j'ai un poste
où j'ai écrite heures puis je me dis
quoi
allez une cantate de bach ça peut
préférer et je m'endors dans la rade
vient de mozart ou de bas rhin
essayez ça et vous verrez que les petits
soucis disparaissent faut pas avoir peur
m
bon
michel serrault dernière question de
quelle question aimeriez vous avoir la
réponse
je voudrais savoir pourquoi je suis dans
le dans le lot pourquoi nous pensons
toujours à nous voilà nous pourquoi je
pense à moi pourquoi tu pense à toi
pourquoi tu penses à 3 pourquoi c'est
normal de concerts joie je lui reconnais
un peu de de présence pour les autres
voilà et comment ça se fait qu'on est
tous les uns et les autres replier sur
nous-mêmes et qu'on a finalement on a
peur de l'autre et michel parent d'un
bouquet de croyants est ce que vous
pensez que vous allez retourner un jour
le duo voire 0 oui mes débuts je pense
que quand je joue la commune bien
souvent je pense à jean et quand
pour moi c'est des cds vacances sur
terre encore si je pense que pour un tas
de gens mais je des retrouvailles